and as Google started we all doing this
with commodity Hardware here so also the
recording okay so hi and welcome so I
didn't prepare in one-hour talks I would
probably be about 3035 minutes so we
would catch up a bit on schedule
a bit about a foreign a consistent I
would like to explain a bit more what I
mean with foreign but we're delighted I
meet up so there's awful things outside
from for me about myself I'm working
since lightly at Quantico which is a
data science consultancy project company
where we working a long time projects
with customers spread out about across
Europe and you yes my main open source
contributions are in the Apache air on
Apache Park air project both if you do a
big lot of big data things or you really
how can use you've probably heard of
them but often people don't have an idea
what these projects actually are about
in my work I work mostly with Python but
I'm always interfacing with other
languages because there's not only
Python in the company but they're like
our data science language is like our or
a lot of systems are written in Java
which are meant for like customer
relationship systems what you have to
connect your 2d designs important thing
there's my Twitter and github handle
follow me on twitter if you want to get
the slides later on there will be no
link just on my Twitter account where PI
different PI data meet up so it's about
Python people often argue or fight about
if you should use - or if you should use
our but in the end it shouldn't actually
be about fighting and we just the - you
should use but as you should think of
can use Python can use our each of them
have have their benefits like one is
maybe more suited to statistics known
people the other one is we can do more
general-purpose things and in the end
you just don't only I want to argue and
use both of them but you actually want
to use a whole suit of programming
languages because your colleagues just
don't work in Python and they don't want
to work in Python because they doing
Network administration they're doing
customer relationship programs and so on
so - katadyn from them you have to talk
with them and that brings us to the
thing when I think of Python I can work
every in everything in Python but
there's really a problem because that's
not just me there are also other people
and the problem comes from there that we
have different ecosystems they often in
their own client kind of like conference
fields so like we're now at a PI date
have meet up with people are thinking
about Python the they were doing maybe
some kind of our they're using pandas
using numpy and when they're talking
about sparkly using PI spark or sparkler
and things that people are concentrated
about docker containers but two weeks
ago I gave a similar talk slightly
adapted here to the communities Berlin
buzzwords and I'm burnin passwords
people think about they want to code in
Scala they want to code in Java and
there's not really anyone to taking you
seriously if you're saying I'm working
full-time with Piper the people there
are concerned about scaling things with
fleeing or elasticsearch and everyone
who is using spark over there is using
Scala no one takes you seriously if you
say Pais pocket it's like okay you're
crazy you're just doing toy examples and
there's another fruit community people
often forget which is a huge one is that
you have asked ul based databases and
like they're the main horses you have
JDBC ODBC access or another custom
protocol like the phosphorous protocol
is turning out like an industry standard
but there you see are three different
communities typically if you're in a
company they're just kind of bigger all
those free exists and people often
they're like in their silos not talking
to each other but in the end we have a
problem that we need to solve because
when we want to do some kind of data
science we want to build they have
pipelines or make an end-to-end data
product we need to connect all three of
those and probably even more like
c-sharp main administration systems so
we need to connect them typically we
write something in Java we copy it then
in another language so we can simulate
what's going on there and also taking
two systems connecting to each other
always means you need to write a
converter and there's probably another
company using the same ear pre system
with some other data science tact and
they will write another converter which
is slightly different and you get into a
space where you're writing a lot of
converters trying to get them fast
probably mostly you're just happy with
them working and not fast but just get a
data out of there and also the base
discussion is always we have - where are
we one professor the other one and
if you have multiple teams working
together one is a Python you monitor our
team you still want that I can exchange
that heels and not about just yeah we
keep everything a pipe now we keep
everything in bar and you just lose so
in the end we have maybe an echo system
where you have like on the top like the
systems you used to compute things on
your data and on the bottom you have
resistance where your data are stored
and I'm working in the Apache IRA
project and that's kind of one of this
proposed solutions which you can use as
an intermediary thing so Apache errors
always it's a big open source project
and it's always sold as like bringing
everything solving orders connection
problems magically a lot of this how can
use articles just don't go in deaf so
when I talk to people about Apache arrow
they're thinking it's kind of magic but
I don't understand what it's doing also
main thing is that as an end user you
will not see this so it's kind of good
to know that it's there it will
hopefully solve things but it's not
magic but Apache arrow is the open
source project which has the core idea
that it's taking just defining a
standard data structure columnar data or
table data if you know what a data frame
is it defines the memory structure that
how a data frame should look like in
memory so that if you have different
systems all of these systems have a
common denominator where to communicate
with and this just defining data
structure is kind of boring and people
will not use it because data structures
is something which is easily defined so
in the Apache Aero project we also bring
you code that you can actually access
this data structure not just in Python
but in a huge set of languages and we
also make sure that in each language
it's the same data structure so if you
have memory in a Python program and you
have a c-sharp program that you can just
reference the same memory you know not
even copy it but reference the same
memory and keep working on that and we
also build building blocks around that
that if you have an existing system that
you can
connect this existing system to another
system or that you have adapted us now
the first main thing is if you read a
sentence above what Apache air is it's a
common calmer representation columnar is
always fancy thing but you first
understand why you need it if you look
at how to structure your data for your
CPU like our main use case is that we
have a table we can store it in a
database it's a 2d structure but in the
end our memory in our computers is just
one D so we have to decide on how do we
map this 2d structure to 1d elements and
there are typical just too obvious
layout it's like row pick a pick a row
and each value at one after another
we're just a traditional layout here
them which is like most database my zero
and prosperous story data on disk which
is really useful if you had running a
website and you have a table of log
entries and when you want if want to
access this table you want to know the
title of the block to count enough to
block the offer off the block and your
main interest is just in all values of
this one row so putting them all
together at the same place it's just the
obvious choice and in data science
analytics you normally are more
interested and working on one column at
a time like I look at the price column
please give me the average price give me
the maximum price and so on then you
just all your tasks are just based on
getting those values from this one
column and then interleaving each column
with each value of like you're taking
the session ID and have having all those
values in between from the other columns
until you access the next value of that
column is not so beneficial because the
CPUs optimized that you can always fetch
chunks of memory and work on chunks of
memory so if there's if there are values
in between you're just wasting your
bandwidth and that's why you're in a
latex prefer coma data
now connecting the data systems together
with kind of a standard there already
solutions that the solutions they have
some kind of unfortunate effects like
everyone knows that in every system you
can import export CSV files and CSV
files always work and the even sometimes
really fast because everyone knows
people will export CSV files so they
invest a lot of time in making CSV fast
but in the end CSV is human readable
that means also it's not a good machine
readable in the end that makes it also
slow it could be a lot faster and it's
row wise so it's not wrecked actually
matching that how we want to represent
data and memory there is packet files
which is the typical thing if you use
spark on another big data system which
where you have Kalama data on disk and
you can load it and also in a lot of
other systems so nowadays like
everything that supporting data Alex
will have a package support and even
older systems like SAS and are also
adding a key support so you can read
those five so you're quite safe nowadays
also with using parquet as the base
format but the thing it's a file format
its main focuses on getting data faster
disk so it's you realizes and compresses
the data in a fast way but it's still
making modifications to your data and
making what if we gave you so data means
it takes time so passing data between
two systems and even if you do this
quite often this is really costly again
and sometimes you just think yeah memory
access is fast so copying data is okay
so you're realizing it takes a bit more
but it may be fast but in the end 10
gigabyte per second sister raid you have
on a laptop sounds fast if you maybe
only have like one gigabyte data set but
if you copy that quite often between two
systems this adds up so even if your
days it's hundred megabytes copying it
hundred times which is a typical thing
that can happen if you switch switch
between two systems it takes some time
so this this is actually the number
which looks really fast but if you just
experienced this input in in a
real-world example you will get really
not you will really feel that so it's
kind of pain always today and there also
a thing dataframe is a typical data
structure you get an R you have a data
frame in pandas gives you a data frame
and SPARC also has its own data frame
implementation they are all quite
similar in the background everything is
totally different implemented and
they're always kind kind of nuances like
how our nulls
handled how a string type represented a
memory and so on they're quite different
so if you want to implement an algorithm
you can implement it for one of those
trees but you can't reuse the
implementation for another data frame
implementation you have to start from
scratch again because a lot of things
different for that in error we have like
distinct separate implementations for
different languages um of our memory
format so that if you working in Java
you can load our memory in Java and
don't have any dependencies on a C++
library the same thing goes if you're
working it's just us you don't have a
dependency of Java but if you if you
work with this two together we also have
tests that you can pass it just around
and passing data around here just means
giving you the reference to the thing in
memory not copying data and a lot of
languages is nice to have but the thing
is always you're not just talking here
about having to program languages you
talking about bringing communities
together that's an important aspect I
learned in this project because normally
you you always talk with like-minded
totally like-minded people in a in a
pack open-source project like everyone
in pandas is using Python so you have
kind of common finger but if you're
working in it working in error is not
kind of like that thing you have people
working in Java doing data engineering
or data ingestion and you have people in
Python that just care about machine
learning in the end so they have totally
different interests they need to talk
together because management that yeah
yeah if we have to speak Edda said we
have this machine learning guy so do
some use case on that
so you always have to be like get people
talking find like common wording so
people actually understand what the
other one wants to do and yeah get some
social interaction and having just eight
instructors it's probably boring it's
probably nothing end-users will use so
having something on top which makes it
usable is Right quite important and the
main and feature of Apache arrow a from
- world is we provide really fast pack
area so if you're using panas and you
have colleague I mean presenting big
datasets in spark writing them out you
normally use ply arrow to you read these
pocket files and get them into Python
that's like 80% what our users do and
there are other cool things which are
coming to startup it's like there's
Gandiva which gives you really fast
expressions with that are just
just-in-time compiled meaning you can
write complex expressions in Python and
then there's a just-in-time compiler
that can map that to filters and these
filters can be will be life compared to
what your CPU supports which is just
getting the last bit of out of CPU
performance and can filter on arrow
structures which can also push down and
okay files and getting more like we have
now because you don't only work on one
machine but you often have to use case
that you send big chunks of data around
of a network protocol would you need
some things like remote procedure call
II and authentication so we extended GI
PC from Google with some mechanics so
you can send chunks of data frames of a
network but with some special hooks at
it if you receive the data in this like
framework implementation you get a
reference to the data in the network and
don't actually copy it because normally
network protocols will the way be fast
with low latency but they have small
amount of data so they don't care about
copying data two or three times but when
you get large chunks of data copying it
two or three times means you need at two
or three times bigger instance which is
always a bit annoying and
the most interesting things for users
nominee arrow is back end technology
powering things and so as an end user
like probably 95% in the room you will
not use arrow in the end but you will
use a system that is based on arrow and
that's made fast the arrow nowadays a
media is pushing data frames on CPU of
GPUs which is basically built up on
arrow so that they have a data frame
implementation which can pull data from
CPU memory into the GPU without any
transformations and the other popular
thing is if we use spark 2 since version
2.4 readers append a CDF function in
there which gives you the ability to
write fast aggregation functions with
Python or just fast modifications
functions before that you had a lot of
serialization going on because - code in
SPARC is always executed in a separate
process from the actual spark process
and we're using that now for Python and
Ferrara so that you get really fast
execution data you don't have to fall
back to Scala if you want to write
custom things and
[Music]
there's also like things like from you
my first time all my second use case
after Park here reading was I have a
database which comes in this ODBC
protocol everything there is optimized
for latency so just giving you results
from a career really fast but only with
just one data point coming out but if
you're doing data science machine only
you just want all data so you get really
big chunks of data and that wasn't
really a fast in there so I wrote
together with him colleague we wrote an
adapter that you can access databases
which follow the ODBC standard and get a
data back as - data frames or error
tables in this case and then converted
to a panda's data frame so that if
there's a big result set that it's
really fast and the other thing which
brings three talks together like it's
evening is that another have a user of a
petty error where you also don't see a
petty error as an end user is cat or
take their throne we'll talk about what
it's really doing in there
but things to keep in mind how to take
is a heavy user of the pack a reader and
also if you do that with pandas
dataframes you know that a lot of things
like strings and sometimes even if you
hang around with nullable ins until the
latest version there will be object
columns so there's no real pandas type
but it's just type object so the pandas
dead pandas type system is quite small
quite limited and if you want to work
with things like structured or string
data it don't doesn't give you a real
type and there are some other components
in arrow which we could using how to
take or which we use in color take which
are available an arrow in other
languages so if someone would do in
avvocato take an implementation in like
Scala
they could use these components but now
I
Sergi about an opensource artifact which
you may or may not know and if you know
it you probably just known it from like
passwords articles and I've just used
some slides so the main question is does
it really actually work because things
on slides is pretty but you don't know
how if something really works or if
something really promises what it does
until you actually just seen it working
so I'm taking a real-life example which
buffered me a bit you have an earpiece
system which is written in Java and the
vendor is also saying okay cool system
everyone ear P world is doing Java so we
don't need to provide a non Java client
but just be Stanek inform here's a JDBC
client you can use you don't have to
write a custom client for us but for me
as a Python user I want to write my
pipelines in Python I want to do the
data cleaning up - so I don't want to
deal with a Java system because that's
not a word I'm normally working in and
in the end I have business analytics
people at the end who want to use my to
clean up dataset and they working are
the main problem in the I understand
this can be run like like hopping from
one to another like when we're working
on the Java people can give me data
export I can work on the data export
them and do analysis and so on and the
our people can take a data export from
Python again and work on that but when
you want to take this life and doing
like small batches in live system yet
you can't do just data exports and on
and on because it will be released
though so we actually want to have this
in one process and that's the really
good thing about arrow you can connect
all these free languages all these
freedom runtimes in one single process
and you don't even need to copy the data
between Java and Python but you can't
just work on a result in that simple
example we have in our Java library and
adapter which
talk to you JDBC client the JDBC client
gives you a result set and JDBC resulted
in Java and there is a nice package
called type which gives you the ability
to call Java functions from - in the
same process and then this pipe Java
code EMU's typical Java just-in-time
compiling to give me a fast access code
the fast conversion from these jdbc
resultset to a narrow structure then I
have my formerly resulted in a nice
common our data structure which is just
like a data frame and I have a magic
function in arrow which is called PI
Harrow JVM record batch which basically
takes a Java table and take looks inside
of that and actually just pulls out a
memory pointer and keeps a reference to
the memory structure in Java so that it
doesn't get garbage collected and puts
this memory pointer into the same -
structure and then I have a pipe
instructor referencing the memory coming
for out of Java and I can just use this
structure to get a panda's data frame
out of that and we're gonna move the
kind of data frame on the Java data
without copying it out in my case is
just two two or three columns but if you
have a really big data set and it's
coming from Java you don't want to have
it copied will have maybe copies already
been you do any modifications on that
data frame but you can work with that
and the nice thing is when you are
stepping onto are there's the package
called reticulate which you can use to
call Python code anakin can just use
this package called the Python code I
just written there for my JDBC X's with
some data cleaning on on top and I got a
Python PI Aero table back and there is a
reticulated has a PI to our phone which
you can use to take a reference pointer
from an object from Python and transform
it to a native our structure and we have
like this record bed franklin i had in
python which takes the memory pointer we
also have that in our which is magically
called when you call this pi tree off
and gives you then an our arrow data
frame which and just looks like a native
app object and has not hyphenated
anymore but still girlfriend is the same
data and you can just use it and look at
it at a table with with an R data frame
and there was after JDBC client there
was no copying worth it in that code so
that's really nice and you can pass on
data from one system to another with one
remark and this is only working in the
next arrow version so the first example
is working since quite a while this one
is just a preview but that's the main
idea I think not many people are using
now the ability to you pass data from
Java to Python to R in one process so
the real use case or usage if you're a
Python user if you want to see this is
working that you have accommodate in
structure which would get you rid of
like writing it up the code is that you
actually will use pandas and in panna
see where is read and repack here or 2
per K and in the backend error is there
for you which powers and pack a reader
which is the same exact same code if you
do a 2 packet or from pack a in R and
also you can use to be DBC to connect to
a database which has an ODBC driver like
MS equal or so and get your results back
in PI as a kind of data frame a lot
faster than if you use the built in
pandas or read SQL function both cases
normally speed ups are like like in the
times of one one hundred times faster so
it's really significant
and being a bit large project or a
really big field where you can work on
things the main things that are coming
up in the project and arrow is as
especially on my site is when you have
accomodation structure you actually want
people to use it or you want to use the
power that you have one data structure
with which connects a lot of things you
want to connect it to even more things
so that if you come up with a new system
you don't have to write a block code to
all like ten lists since you already
connecting to but you just want one
connected to an arrow and all your other
system have arrow connections on for me
nowadays I'm having I'm facing north and
Postgres instances prosperous drivers in
python are cash fast but if I get a big
result set back it takes quite some time
to get a result in the data frames so
get writing more adapters like taking
processed results getting your dip
directly data frame back it's one of
those new things which would like to
have an arrow the other things we were
building in arrow nowadays is that we
also support a bit more that people have
datasets like huge collections of flat
files and with some library on top that
maybe manages them but we also want to
provide like the building blocks for
these libraries can use in many
languages static in Lotus datasets and
have the data structure memory without
actually taking care of the management
of the number of files and also I
mentioned that at least free known data
frame implementations that are totally
distinct providing a memory structure
where you can build up data frame
implementations on top it's just half
way worst McKinney is always talking
about pandas 2.0 probably not happening
immediately but one of the buildings
lots of pandas to data will be arrow so
that you can then use the arrow
structures taking data from other
systems and also having just a big good
basis for building a new data frame
implementation so that
algorithm written for that item data
frame can also may be used for the our
data frame which could be also built on
top of that so if you implement a really
complex algorithm in C++ which is really
fast they all need to take care of
implementing one reversion for Python
and one version for our I just can use
the one version for both of them yeah
that was my basic over
you about what is arrow and I hope you
all gotten a basic understanding if
you're reading in error articular next
time telling you that it's some magic
doing columnar systems fast and you
actually get an understanding about what
is this magic and why your aren't seeing
that directly in your programs any
questions yeah no there will be maybe as
in half of extension on top but the main
thing about arrow is that's defining how
to structure is looking we provide some
algorithms that can modify the data but
we don't actually provide reprocessing
but they actually processing framework
on top that's a thing that's more like
things which panas or spark are doing
and arrows model backing how the memory
is thought
so I'm not happy some spark experts work
anti-white slower it should normally be
at least as fast as they actually focus
you really am working corner side so if
you stay in Python row-by-row won't be
fast because it's the one main
constraint for optimization that we want
to make home operations fast
so this robo won't help you here you can
use libraries like number or so if you
go over row by row we followed but
that's not a thing whatever is doing
arrows providing you just the backing
memory and hope now that's still calm
operations so if you if you have a row
by row use case no only if you if you at
the end if you would work with a panda's
data frame and the pentose data frame
would be efficient for you
then arrow is a good thing if you need
something to communicate with our
persistence
in practice we we really just used to
map data at the address in the memory
and reading the value of the popular
integers in this case here this library
Chivers are starting for us a JVM in the
background and as it's running the same
process it's also running in the same
address space and we can just ask that
the Java data structure and what is your
what is the memory address of your
Kalama data it will give you dan the
memory address and we can just construct
a Python object which references a
memory address but really just an
integer passing around
which also you have to take care of if
you pass it pass that integer around you
also need to take out that you don't
destroy the object is holding onto this
memory because in Java if an object is
deleted or is not longer referenced the
Java system is open to just destroy at
any time so if it's if the object
holding the arrow memory is just
destroyed and you don't have a reference
to that here you're backing structures
destroyed no because a narrow definition
every column is immutable so if you do
any mutations you have to allocate a
writing new memory
no play for J doesn't work with that
because PI for J is starting a Java
Runtime in another process so you don't
have to same address space so the
interplay for J case if you get an
integer address it's only usable in the
in the Java process so in Python that's
a scalar case the Scala you have to use
PI PO che
you have inter park you have two main
Scala process which has memory and if
you use these pandas PDFs you it just
copies the data from Scala to the Python
process which is the single copy if you
don't use to depend on CDF it serialize
the data to so another row by row format
and converts that sense it over to - up
- users in another store approach to
deserialize it but it's just three
testing processes so you have to copy
a cross-platform it you mean between
different operating systems yeah but
that works but you still have a copy
done that yeah but that's okay if you
that's like for the flight every see
case where your copy between two house
yeah yeah it works on Linux Windows and
Mac and purchased under so the main
limitation at the moment is that you
have to have a little endian system
which means that you can use all
Playstations but it also works if you
have a Windows laptop and you have a
Raspberry Pi which is not running into a
CPUs you can use the same memory and
just copy it over
you
the main thing we gpus have also kind of
bit different architecture and you can
that's why this w data frames work also
[Music]
the main use case of error is that you
don't serialize at all so that's the
selling point you have one memory
structure there's support in all our
runtimes you need to serialize if you
write if you use something else like
taki is the typical example because it's
quite symmetric error but it's a five
format it's also taking care of size so
it it takes column by column the data
tries to make simple encoding techniques
to use not so much CPU because it knows
which is a type of the data and then
uses compression of power that the
encoded data there you have to benefit
its has smaller size and if you send it
over a slower network it's faster than
it's faster to spend a CPU time and then
send it over network then just copying
the data plane to network
thank you very much
[Applause]